hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my top 10 picks for Young
Justice storylines so careful for
spoilers for stuff that happened during
season one and two I'll be addressing
big story points that they just kind of
left hanging in the air so there are a
couple like really clear plot lines they
could pick up with and I think it'd be
easiest for them to just pick up with
the threads they left off with but
obviously it's been a while maybe they
have a couple new ideas of where they
want to take the characters based on the
storylines that they set up in that
finale but just going down the list
black beetle in the reach standing trial
at OA so the Lantern Corps probably
locked a bunch of them up in as aqualad
said bar so oom is having problems on
Mars of an unspecified nature so that's
probably white Martian related next big
story point and if you don't know who he
is he's basically like a green Martian
like Martian Manhunter who has all the
same powers but also has a scarab that
makes him the green beetle so he has
blue beetle powers on top of Martian
powers so it's like extra cool so that's
another big thing that they need to
follow up on in the light they say you
know next big thing was broken in half
so the final membership as of the finale
was FanDuel savage Rachel Ghul who
supposedly died but they carried his
body off and said he'll return you know
so lazarus pit that means he's coming
back lex luthor queen bee the brain
clarion in Black Manta but you know that
Lex Luthor you know normally an evil
person helped out the heroes at the end
gained a commendation
so that's kind of the way that he works
so even though he seemed like he had
turned good at the end he's always going
to be evil he always has a plan within a
plan so the light will probably reform
they'll continue to be a big villain
they were like the overarching villain
for most of the series so like you have
the Justice League the light was kind of
like the TV shows version of the secret
society of super villains or the
injustice game really like this
universes version of that big villain
team-up so that band will get back
together eventually but separate from
that Lex Corp selling the evil soda
to try and soften people's minds to do
whatever Lex Luthor wanted them to do
which I really like this plot point
because it's kind of funny
it'd be like saying coca-cola is an evil
corporation that only wants to make more
money so they sell you coke so that
you'll drink it it will soften your mind
and you'll be more susceptible to buy
their other products so everybody like
collectively just like put their soda
cans down on their desk right now so
then moving down the list you have dark
side the light is working with dark side
via Vandal Savage
like they meet each other like their old
fraternity brothers like they went to
college together or something so the
thing about dark side on the TV show the
funny thing is is the same actor that
does Aqualad Black Manta Black Lightning
said that he also wanted to do the voice
for Darkseid so he'll come back in some
way but I just love the idea that you
have Aqualad you know really important
person inside the Young Justice team is
also voicing like the biggest villain in
the universe but the thing about
Darkseid is that you have to have some
big reason for him entering the game so
to speak like you only put them on the
game board when you're getting ready for
some uber crazy huge story because the
whole idea is that he's this
insurmountable force so I do see this
scenario where Aqualad in the team
they're working with the Justice League
now just because they earned the right
Darkseid probably comes in enhance the
Justice League their asses so they're
out of commission so the younger team
has to step up like Young Justice is a
show about the young characters it's not
so much about the Justice League so
usually they wind up being a plot point
to help further Young Justice character
development in the tease at the end of
season two is that they're now like
qualified to work alongside the Justice
League so the next big step would be
them filling in for the Justice League
but in order to do that you have to
bring in somebody who can defeat the
Justice League by himself which is
Darkseid so that might be what they use
him for but you can let me know like
what do you want Darkseid to do when he
first comes back but obviously he's such
a big villain do you kinda have to
string him along you can't just use him
a little bit in then never bring him
back next big story point is the TANF
ring her father from the helmet of fate
and the whole thing is is that it kind
of traps you like once you put it on it
won't let you take it off so you're dr.
fate until someone else comes along so
the idea is is that during season three
they'd introduce a new dr. fate in
didn't go really well but they did
introduce this new sort character who's
a medical student who becomes the new
dr. fate so they could use him on the
animated show he could help Satana free
her father from the helmet of fate by
becoming doctor fate himself next big
thing is Arsenal he's kind of like an
antihero he's kind of on like a Red Hood
type arc where he goes solo and he's a
little more hardcore than the team like
he's almost too hardcore to work with
the team all the time so they could do a
Red Hood arc where they resurrect Jason
Todd and they could just team up to do
things that the normal team thinks is
too crazy to do and then of course like
last big story point is in addressing
the final fate of Wally West
you know just completely vanishes into
we don't know what because the Speed
Force doesn't exist you know surprise
dot dot it does exist he will probably
materialize so you know part of season 3
could be them learning about the Speed
Force in then finding way to save him
whether or not they're actually able to
achieve that but I do think that they
would try to bring him back at least by
the end of the series but the thing is
is that we're just talking about like
season 3 and there's so many big story
points they could address that they
might not have time to get through
everything so I'm totally cool with them
stringing some plot lines along into
season 4 so I do think that there's a
solid chance that they could get a
season 4 but a lot of that just depends
on how season 3 performs which platform
they put it on like is it going to be on
Cartoon Network is it going to be on
Netflix who's going to help fund it like
where's the money coming from
so animation is really expensive
obviously there was the whole thing
about them not selling enough toys to
the right audience so they canceled the
series after season 2 they haven't
really said anything about where they're
going to stick season 3 but what they
might do if Netflix is willing to pony
up the extra money to help produce the
series is they might dump it on Netflix
so either way it'll be fine I'll do
videos for everything when it gets here
will be a lot of fun but the funny thing
is is the Greg we spent the Creator
was like you know people be careful
about the stuff you're tweeting at me
because legally I'm not able to use your
ideas so like the more stuff do you give
me the less that I'm able to do in the
TV series he made it sound like the more
you asked him to do the
les he's able to do which i think is
kind of funny it doesn't work exactly
that way but like from a legal
standpoint he can't use other people's
ideas but as for Netflix versus Cartoon
Network I mean like Adventure Time is a
big show on Cartoon Network that is
going off the air like that's going to
be going away so I think it just depends
on how much money Cartoon Network feels
like it could make off of advertisements
and toy sales and things like that so
like they're hurting for new programming
Young Justice is something that people
really want so they could totally keep
it for themselves
so don't be surprised if you hear that
it's not coming to Netflix is coming to
Cartoon Network but either way it would
eventually go to Netflix
I think Netflix just bought the rights
to the first two seasons like when they
bought the first two seasons they didn't
buy the rights to season three so they
have to be negotiated separately from
that so that'll probably like the next
big story like when they announce where
it's coming but I'm not really expecting
it to drop to like really late 2017
early 2018 I really I think early 2018
is a little more likely but be sure to
subscribe to get more Young Justice I'll
be doing bonus videos till it gets here
so what I'm gonna do next is is a Doctor
Strange video for the sequels that I
think they should do next
so why you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for like that big
clip from the final episode and you can
click here for my Young Justice flash
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five from behind
the camera because you can't see my face
right now
I'll see you guys tonight
you